the former secretary of state john kerry
this week became the first biden
administration official to travel to
china now before he made that trip i
spoke to him
and began by asking how urgent it is
that the world takes action on climate
change
well it's extremely urgent uh i mean the
word urgent
is is totally applicable to the current
crisis that we're in because
countries are simply not getting the job
done
uh even if we did everything that we set
out to do in the paris agreement
the earth's temperature is going to
increase a very significant amount
perhaps as much as 3.7 degrees or more
and the reason and the reason for the
real urgency now is that
because we're not getting done what we
said we do in paris it's actually
heading towards four degrees or more
that's beyond catastrophic in the
consequences to food production
water habitability in various parts of
the planet the melting of ice the sea
level rise
the warming all the consequences so we
have an opportunity to get on track
the united states has a summit next week
the president biden is hosting
and we will be setting forth our plan to
try to do our part
and we hope to raise ambition among all
nations over the course of these next
months
as you say at the earth day summit uh
president biden is expected to
tell us what the us's emissions targets
are
given the fact that you're the second
biggest emitter in the world
and that you haven't even been in the
paris agreement in recent years
is it not the us's duty to actually set
the most ambitious targets in the world
well it's the us's duty certainly to
return to the paris agreement as
president biden has done
and to work with other nations to do the
maximum
possible i can assure you that the
united states will do its part
to help keep uh us on track
to have a 1.5 degree rise
the limit that's what that's our goal
and then to head to 2050 where we would
be net zero
and we hope that other nations will join
us
to raise the ambition to be able to hold
that 1.5 degree
limit on the increase of earth's
temperature obviously to do that we're
all going to have to do our part i mean
yes we are number two in the world in
emissions
and and uh we helped to put paris
agreement together and now we're going
to do everything in our power to help
get glasgow
to do what it needs to do to put the
world on a track in these next 10 years
to accomplish our goal
but the the simple reality is no one
nation does this alone
even if the united states went to zero
tomorrow where the uk did or europe
the fact is that uh you know china which
is almost 30
of the world's emissions other countries
india russia
indonesia japan there are a lot of
industrialized countries that are
contributing to this challenge
20 nations all of whom are invited to
president biden's summit
are responsible for about 81 of all the
emissions
so to solve this problem those 20
countries have to lead the way
we recognize that responsibility we are
very sorry for uh the last four years
with the president who
didn't care about science and who didn't
have a real rationale for pulling out
but he was the only president in the
world the only leader in the world
who pulled out of this agreement
president biden said the first thing you
do as president is return
we've done that and now with this summit
we're going to try and bring nations to
the table to do what we need to do to
get the job done
for future generations of course there's
a responsibility as you say
on everyone but particularly those
countries that make up 80
of emissions at the same time you know
the us is responsible for
up to 15 percent of emissions china is
responsible for 30
you know some of our viewers might be
thinking is it really going to make a
difference if people in the uk
eat less meat or cycle more when you
consider these colossal emissions
coming out of the us and china
of course it makes a difference because
every country has to join this effort
as i said a moment ago no one country no
one entity
like the eu can solve the problem this
is
this is a unbelievable monument
the climate crisis to the need for
multilateralism
this is why we have a u.n this is why we
bring nations together
and unfortunately the united states
became a renegade
in the last four years under the
non-leadership of president trump
but we are now uh back
and present with a very aggressive uh
series of initiatives in order to try to
make up for lost time
we need to address this challenge and
the beauty of it is
this creates jobs in in the addressing
of this in the deployment of solar
of wind in the further explorations with
respect to hydrogen
fuel in the creation perhaps of storage
or longer term batteries
these are all jobs you make electric
vehicles you have people are going to
make them
i mean this is the biggest economic
opportunity the world has seen
since the industrial revolution nearly a
third of the
world's emissions come from china you
are planning to
travel to china this week to discuss
climate issues
we have been in touch with china i've
talked to my counterpart
a number of times we
recognize that china nearly 30 percent
of the world's emissions
is essential to resolving this crisis
and our hopes are that china is prepared
to
assume responsibility as we are and as
other nations are
this is not a moment where
any nation can not
step up to raise the ambition that paris
envisioned
uh and and what we're doing now is not
something that we've instigated
particularly
it's the automatic follow-on to the
paris agreement
that we would reconvene we will take
stock of where we are
there's a formal take stock in three
years but already
the u.n agency responsible for making
judgments about the science the ipcc
has told us two years ago that we have
about 12 years
within which to make the most critical
decisions to reduce
the most damaging impacts of climate
we're now two years down the road we
haven't done that yet
we have whatever nine years eight years
to make those decisions
and that's what glasgow is about it's a
moment when we all come together from
around the world
and we commit to do more there are of
course pretty big disagreements between
the us and china
on trade also you've described the
treatment of the
uyghur muslims as a genocide can you
really have a productive conversation
with client china about climate change
absolutely of course we can climate
change is about survival of the planet
every nation has a stake in the outcome
of the climate issue
and and and big powerful nations
historically
have proven that they have the ability
to be able to discuss difficult issues
even as they disagree on them when i was
secretary of state
we dealt very directly with russia even
after we had sanctioned them for the
invasion of crimea and ukraine
we continued to have tough conversations
about that even as we made progress on
the iran nuclear agreement on the paris
agreement
on other environment issues so yes uh
you know president reagan and mikhail
gorbachev met at reykjavik and lowered
the number of nuclear weapons pointing
at each other
despite the fact reagan thought the
soviet union was the evil empire we can
have those conversations and that is the
real stuff of diplomacy
that's what you have to do is try you
know the failure of diplomacy is war
and the object of the diplomacy is to
avoid that i am keen to ask you about
the protests that we've seen
in minneapolis after another black man
shot by police
cause it comes after the killing of
george floyd which sparked protests
around the world what's your
reaction to what we've seen well
obviously
uh we're living through a very painful
moment in our country with respect to
race uh and uh policing
and the challenges of keeping
communities whole and together
we've had a terrible history
unfortunately
of uh police stops and a relationship
with
african-americans particularly but with
you know racial overtones for a long
period of time
and we need to get beyond it that's one
of president biden's
real missions that he has taken on is to
heal america and bring america back
together
but at the same time as i say that and
people are angry and frustrated at the
deaths
of people at the hands of uh you know
really
incomprehensible situations uh
nevertheless uh we
we also cannot condone or accept the
fact that the legitimate protest
to that is go out and loot a walmart
or destroy property protest is protest
and it's important that that protest
be non-violent otherwise you begin
confusing everything and losing
the importance of the message that you
have but these are serious
challenges and i used to be a prosecutor
i know how
difficult policing is but at the same
time
i also know the lives that uh
young african-americans particularly
have led in our country
being stopped in places and for
circumstances that no white person would
be stopped in
and so we have to meet that challenge
we've got some tough conversations to
have and some actions
to take one last quick question to
squeeze in because i know it's something
that we
talk about an awful lot in the uk uh
analyzing that relationship between the
uk prime minister and the u.s
president how would you describe the
relationship between joe biden and boris
johnson
well i the best of my knowledge they
they are friends and get along well and
and we're working together on a lot of
key
issues that matter to both of us so i
have no knowledge of anything else